münchen klinik bogenhausen
markus schopp erarbeitet als fach kläger
auf der intensivstation er hat
spätschicht
shopper liebt seinen beruf auch wenn er
sehr anstrengend ist an allen ecken und
enden fehlen pflegekräfte nicht erst
seit
krones hat glaube ich jetzt überhaupt
keiner mehr bock irgendwie auf diese
pandemie was jetzt an sich ganz gut ist
für die pflege dass man einfach mal dass
die pflege auch mal so ein bisschen den
vordergrund gerückt ist dass man brauch
man sieht okay was machen wir was müssen
wir leisten für ganze bonuszahlung ist
uns ein bisschen tropfen auf den heißen
stein so jetzt geben wir ihnen einen
bonus von 500 fasnet ist ja aber im
endeffekt das löst das grundsätzliche
problem nicht der anspruch an dem beruf
ist da nur die leute fehlen einfach
gerade noch die patienten ist seit zehn
tagen bei uns kam über den
rettungsdienst wurde draußen aufgefunden
schöne ist seit gestern kathrin frey und
die börse hatte gekriegt nähe antivirus
kriegt sie jetzt noch weiterhin dass der
tag acht von zehn alles klar
was tun gegen den personalmangel
die münchner haben eine besondere idee
4000 euro gibt es für jeden mitarbeiter
der eine neue pflegekraft an bord und
auch die neue pflegekraft bekommt 4000
euro prämie
geschäftsführer dr axel fischer hat
damit großen erfolg
etwa 90 pflegekräfte pro jahr konnte er
so zuletzt für seine krankenhäuser
gewinnen
[Musik]
wir wollten schon auch vielleicht mehr
pflegekräfte die aufgehört haben mit dem
beruf auch noch mehr anlocken dadurch
ehemalige auch zu sagen mensch dass wir
selbst oder unsere leute die anrufen zu
sagen mensch ab die nicht los
zurückzukommen deswegen auch eine prämie
also es ging nicht darum die anderen zu
schwächen es ging darum unsere not
praktisch zu lindern ich glaube wären
trotzdem auch weiterhin viele
hausaufgaben zu machen gleichzeitig habe
ich schon die aufgabe auch natürlich in
richtung politik auch zu schauen und zu
sagen okay ändert das system es
funktioniert nicht so
zwar gibt es in münchen prämien für mehr
personal aber viel mehr verdienen als
anderswo tun sie hier auch nicht ist das
nachhaltig und was wünschen sich pfleger
wie marcus schober der schon seit 2004
im beruf ist es musterstaat von ganz
oben einfach auch die möglichkeit geben
zum beispiel
dass die pflege früher in rente geht das
war
steuervergünstigungen hat dass man
einfach ab einem gewissen alter sagt ich
muss keinen nachtdienst machen aber das
ist eigentlich seit es im prinzip was
man es auch in den letzten ein zwei
jahren sieht die belastung auf die
pflege wird so extrem dass sehr viele
einfach den job den rücken kehren man
muss es leider auch sagen es sind sehr
viele gute leute dabei
vanessa an der lucy ist eine von ihnen
sie hat ihren job an den nagel gehängt
16 jahre lang hat sie als gesundheits
und krankenpflegerin in einer klinik
gearbeitet zuletzt in der internistische
notaufnahme am ende war vanessa an der
lucy ausgelaugt hatte keine kraft mehr
also schön persönlich selbst wenn ich
jetzt 1000 euro netto mehr gehabt hätte
macht das ja die bedingungen oder die
umstände nicht besser also das wäre es
für mich kein grund gewesen irgendwie
weiterhin in der pflege zu bleiben
sondern es bedarf halt einfach mehr
personal also in jeder schicht muss man
mindestens ein oder zwei pflegekräfte
mehr sein mit dem gleichen patienten
umfang ich bin so oft abends von einem
acht stunden dienst gekommen und war
weder auf toilette noch habe ein schluck
getrunken oder irgendwie in mein brot
gewissen wenn man einfach keine zeit
dafür hat ja also natürlich hätte ich
mich irgendwie schnell in die küche
setzen können und man klares trinken
können aber das ist halt die zeit die
mir dann letztendlich bei dem patienten
wieder gefehlt hätte und das will man ja
auch nicht ja man ist ja trotzdem mit
herz noch gesundheits und
krankenpflegerin
1,1 millionen pflegekräfte sind
deutschlandweit in krankenhäusern
beschäftigt tendenz minimal steigen in
deutschen kliniken fehlen aber jetzt
schon 50.000 pflegekräften 2030 werden
es über 60.000 sein das brutto
einstiegsgehalt liegt zwischen 2400 und
2900 euro und schichtdienst ist die
regel vanessa an der lucy hat sich für
den flex it entschieden den ausstieg aus
ihrem beruf an ihrem letzten arbeitstag
macht sie dieses foto von sich der
gedanke die pflege zu verlassen ist
eigentlich so heißt nicht in den letzten
vier fünf jahren auch seit ich kinder
habe quasi immer mehr gestiegen und ist
natürlich ein großer schritt zu machen
wolltest ja eigentlich eine herzens
berufung auch ist und man möchte auch
die patienten nicht unbedingt irgendwie
im stich lassen also wenn das jeder
machen würde dann wäre das
gesundheitssystem das wird kollabieren
der druck den vanessa an der lucy spürte
nahm immer weiter zu
klar ist dass durch corona noch mal
heftiger geworden aber letztendlich von
die bedingungen auch vorher schon schon
komisch kann das nicht an irgendeinem
zeitpunkt oder einem jahr festhalten wo
ich das gemerkt habe dass ist auf einmal
irgendwie
abdriftet aber ob die patienten
fallzahlen steigen einfach drastisch man
wird aber gar nicht mehr personal ich
habe auch ganz oft abends im bett
gelegen wo mir dann so sehnen oder
momente kam verdammt jetzt hast du hast
der patienten nicht die telefonkarte
noch geholt obwohl du dir das eigentlich
versprochen hatte das ist halt schon
frustrierend und es macht einen halt
auch traurig dass man halt nicht so für
die patienten einfach da sein konnte wie
man das eigentlich gerne gemacht hätte
oder deshalb vor ein paar jahren noch
konnte
heute arbeitet sie als pflege gutachten
ermittelt beispielsweise den grad der
pflegebedürftigkeit eines menschen keine
wochenend feiertags und nach dienste
mehr dafür mehr zeit mit der familie
da kann die arbeit im krankenhaus nicht
mithalten die meisten kliniken klagen
über zu wenig personal
die sogenannte light pflege hat aus
dieser not ein geschäft gemacht viele
krankenhäuser stellen ihr pflegepersonal
direkt ein wird aber kurzfristig
zusätzliches personal benötigt können
die pflegekräfte auch über
personaldienstleister verpflichten mike
schreier ist einer von ihnen
natürlich wird eine klinik viel lieber
eigenes personal anstellen können aber
natürlich nicht mal ansatzweise das
bieten den mitarbeitern was wir den
mitarbeitern bieten 100 arbeitspensum
ist bei uns eine 35 stunden woche das
fängt da dafür gibt's für einander haben
wir dreieinhalb bis vier stunden weniger
wochen arbeitszeit als die kliniken
weil wir einem anderen tarifvertrag
angehören und das eben machen können und
dann die bezahlung natürlich bewegen uns
schon zwischen 50 und 100 prozent mehr
zu dem was sie wieder weiter in der
klinik verdienen das ist teuer für die
krankenhäuser
personalkosten in der pflege wollen sie
niedrig halten aber die leitfähige macht
das krankenhaus in belastungs zeiten
flexibel
das hat seinen preis viele sagen ich
habe die nase voll ich bin dann immer
arbeiten dann probieren sie die die
laible oder leasing pflege ich habe
mitarbeiter die sagen wenn ich nicht bei
dir wer wo ich auch mal sagen kann ich
brauch jetzt die pause oder ich brauch
jetzt die pause und die pause sich auch
leisten können dann zu hause das ist was
anderes gehen die schweiz oder luxemburg
die din er das nahe ausland wo es noch
andere bedingungen gibt es ist natürlich
paradox sagt obwohl ich natürlich hier
mit geld verdienen aber ich
mein berufliches ethos gibt eigentlich
vor dass es unternehmen wir uns gerne
gegen graf das dass es uns gibt es
absurd wir sind das eine extrem ich sage
jetzt mal die klinik ist das andere
extrem
aber es gibt ja irgendwas dazwischen
noch rund 80 pflegekräfte sind bei mikes
schreier angestellt hin und wieder
arbeitet er auch selbst auf station
wenn ich die möglichkeit habe mir so
tageweise diese bastion über diese
inseln zu schaffen
ja und das ist alles ich freue mich
immer wenn ich eine pflege ich freue
mich einfach immer mal wieder zu
arbeiten und das merkt man umfällt und
ich merke auch also ich finde es
persönlich wichtig einfach weil ich
wissen will wovon ich rede oder wovon
meiner mitarbeiter reden dann kann ich
einfach auf augenhöhe mit sprechen
intensiv pflegerin kerstin ist seit
einem jahr in schreyers team
der schritt in die lege fiel ihr nicht
leicht
man hat angst dass man ständig wechseln
musste es war bei mir nie der fall ich
habe wirklich lange zeit immer auf den
stationen gearbeitet und ich bin auch
immer in super teams reingekommen aber
das ist natürlich immer mein größter
stressfaktor aber es ist natürlich auch
die finanzielle komponente ich konnte
runtergehen von den stunden zahlen und
hat aber trotzdem finanziell keine
einbuße und somit war es auch für meine
gesundheit wesentlich besser ein gutes
faires gehalt ist vielen beschäftigten
in der krankenpflege wichtig für sie ist
das ein ausdruck der wertschätzung eine
studie der uni duisburg essen kommt zu
dem ergebnis dass pflegekräfte viel
verantwortung tragen und deshalb mit dem
gleichen gehalt einsteigen müssten die
ingenieure
aber woher kommt das geld
gesprächstermin beim spitzenverband der
krankenkassen in berlin dem gkv zufolge
lagen die bundesweiten pflegepersonal
kosten zuletzt bei rund 18 milliarden
euro jährlich
die pflege den krankenhäusern bezahlen
sie und ich über unsere
krankenkassenbeiträge und sonst niemand
praktisch sieht eher so aus die
krankenhäuser schauen ihre buchhaltung
und gucken nach wieviel geld geben sie
tatsächlich für pflegekräfte aus dieses
geld melden sie an die krankenkassen da
wird noch ein bisschen geguckt wie ist
die perspektive also es geplant
zusätzliche pflegekräfte einzustellen
sind tariferhöhungen zu erwarten daraus
errechnet sich ein gesamter den die
krankenkassen an die krankenhäuser
bezahlen für die pflege seit 2020 gibt
es dass pflege budget examinierte
pflegekräfte werden nicht mehr über die
fallpauschalen sondern separat
abgerechnet die höhe dieses budgets ist
immer noch ein streitpunkt das verrückte
ist doch die krankenhäuser bekommen 100
prozent der pflege ausgaben von den
krankenkassen erstattet
und das ärgert mich maßlos dass die
krankenhäuser die nicht genug
pflegekräfte einstellen die keine
vernünftigen dienstpläne machen und
dergleichen wir immer wieder auf die
krankenkassen zeigen geld was für pflege
da ist darf man nicht einfach umlenken
um das dach zu decken und fenster zu
streichen die krankenhäuser können mehr
pflegekräfte einstellen die
krankenhäuser können mehr pflegekräfte
ausbilden und sie können die besser
bezahlen die ressourcen sind da sie
müssen es nur tun die krankenkassen
zeigen auf die krankenhäuser die
deutsche krankenhausgesellschaft sagt
auf nachfrage dazu die pflege budgets
werden und dürfen ausschließlich für
gehälter der pflegekräfte verwendet
werden
außerdem würden die krankenkassen die
verhandlung der pflege budgets
blockieren
auch dem gkv-spitzenverband dürfte
bekannt sein dass der arbeitsmarkt für
krankenpflege fachkräfte praktisch leer
ist die krankenhäuser würden sofort
zehntausende pflegekräfte einstellen
wenn es der arbeitsmarkt ermöglichen
würde bei stellenbesetzung problemen in
der pflege in nahezu allen deutschen
krankenhäusern erscheint der vorwurf wie
ein schlechter scherz
an menschen die in der pflege arbeiten
wollen werden hohe ansprüche gestellt
[Musik]
die ausbildung dauert lange und ist
nicht einfach die bundesweite
abbruchquote liegt durchschnittlich bei
30 prozent
und von denen die es schaffen hören
viele schon nach wenigen jahren wieder
auf
dabei wird der beruf von der politik
schon lange beworben
pflege ist zukunft pflege hat zukunft
und wir wollen gerade jungen menschen
auch zeigen dass das ein toller beruf
ist indem man hohe
arbeitsplatzsicherheit in den kommenden
jahren haben wird in dem man in
deutschland überall eine perspektive hat
zu arbeiten
[Musik]
jedes jahr beginnen am friedrich ebert
krankenhaus neumünster etwa 70
auszubildende die sogenannte
generalistische pflegeausbildung die im
jahr 2020 eingeführt wurde
deutschlandweit sind es gut 70.000
azubis in allen pflegeberufen benjamin
schneider ist seit zwei jahren
schulleiter an der schule für
pflegeberufe in neumünster
mal arbeitet pflegebedürftigen mit
kranken mit sterbenden mit kranken
kindern und das kann nicht jeder mann
weiß schon wenn wir die schüler
kennenlernen dem erste theorie blog
mensch das ist ein sehr hoch belasteter
bereich wie kann man das schon zutrauen
der bringt schon genug erfahrung
mitbringt für doch schon genug
persönliche reife mit und welcher
schüler muss vielleicht noch mal ein
bisschen mehr an die hand genommen
werden lena und aleksandra sind im
zweiten lehrjahr der ausbildung zur
generalistischen pflegefachfrau
durch die pandemie wurden sie auf
station noch mal besonders gefordert und
das schon lange vor ihrem
berufsabschluss
man möchte so viel wissen auch sagen wie
möglich so viel ausprobieren bevor das
examen losgeht andererseits ist auch der
druck von der station von den anderen
examinierten da die auch was von dir
erwarten und natürlich sind da stressige
tage da muss man einfach für gemacht
sein denke ich dass man auch diesen
stress aushalten kann aber am ende des
tages weiß man was man getan hat und man
hat eigentlich jeden tag einen prägenden
moment wo man auch noch den tag darüber
nachdenkt zu den praxis einsetzen gehört
immer auch theorie zum beispiel das
richtige lagern von patientinnen und
patienten habt ihr so patienten schon
mal positioniert gesehen lena wie sie
ihnen da deine erfahrung aus da wurde
wer die azubis im pflegeberuf
realistisch auf den arbeitsalltag
vorbereiten will muss von anfang an
klartext reden
tatsächlich ist das bei uns auch immer
wieder thema das wir über die ganzen
probleme die vorherrschen reden einfach
weil die die aus dem alltag auch
mitbringen und
also pflegenotstand pflegepersonal
untergrenze dass es solche begriffe
überhaupt gibt zeigt schon wie schwierig
das system da eigentlich hinter ist und
um die motivation der schüler zu
verstehen muss man in den beruf
tatsächlich arbeiten das ist auch der
grund warum viele viele doch auch in der
pflege bleiben auch wenn steht ford flex
sind natürlich auch immer wieder thema
ist
zurück in münchen
intensivpfleger markus supermacht an der
hauseigenen akademie eine weiterbildung
zum stationsleiter für ihn ein wichtiger
ansporn um den job noch einige jahre
machen zu können
außerdem ist die fortbildung eine
möglichkeit sich zwischendurch aus dem
stressigen station alltag heraus zu
ziehen die münchner klinik will die
pflege auf lange sicht stärken
der beruf pflege auch in der
zusammenarbeit mit dem arzt ist nicht
ausdifferenziert so richtig ich glaube
pflege dem berufs den so wertvollen in
der patientenbehandlung ist kein
kostenfaktor letzten eine sondern auch
ein wertschöpfender erlös faktoren das
muss uns klarer werden in der
kinderklinik schwabing wurde dafür das
projekt maneo ins leben gerufen in der
frühchen und neugeborenenmedizin
arbeiten auszubildende in der pflege und
medizin studierende im praktischen jahr
gemeinsam auf station
teamarbeit auf augenhöhe
das ist das ziel des projekts das durch
eine stiftung gefördert wird
mehr herzlichen bereich ist es so dass
da erst mal wahrgenommen werden muss
dass die pflege eine eigene
professionalität hat die können dinge
die wir als ärzte nicht können und auch
nicht gelernt haben und die sind wichtig
für die versorgung der kinder wenn ich
sondiere dann spuckt das kind immer weil
ich das aber nicht kann und es gehört in
die pflege das ist deren profession und
gemeinsam können wir den patienten an
gut behandeln bei der übergabe tauscht
man sich über medizinische und
pflegerische aspekte aus es ist wichtig
miteinander zu reden damit sich niemand
übergangen oder schlecht informiert
fühlt
so zeichnet sich schon ab dass sich
gesprächskultur durch solche projekte
durch dieses zusammenwachsen bei der
professionen extrem verbessert und
dadurch natürlich auch die
berufszufriedenheit also wenn ich
einfach einen tag hinter mich bringen
der auch stress geladen ist und auch mit
höhen und tiefen ab stattfindet so ist
es trotzdem zufrieden stellende wenn ich
sie man zieht an einem strang es geht in
die richtige richtung es funktionieren
absprache man kann gegenseitig
aufeinander rücksicht nehmen die vom
praktikanten hier das praktikum macht
bis hin zur fachkraft alle professionen
und alle berufsgruppen die merken da ist
ein platz da kann ich wählen da kann ich
meine sorge anbringen da kann ich meine
fragen stellen
die phototherapie aufbau befinden oder
die paneele steht auch für inter
professionelle ausbildung auf der
neonatologie der frühchen und
neugeborenenstation das konzept ließe
sich auch auf andere stationen
übertragen
porsche hat in den letzten monaten als
stationsleitung dieser station von
pflegekräfte eingestellt da würden
manche die tränen in die augen schießen
wenn sie so viele einstellungen hätten
und das kommt nicht von selbst sondern
das ist das projekt die politik hat die
vielen baustellen in der pflege oft
benannt aber zu wenig getan dazu gehört
auch die vermittlung zwischen
krankenkassen und krankenhäusern die
geben sich im streit um die finanzierung
der pflege gegenseitig die schuld hier
muss die politik klare entscheidungen
treffen sonst gibt es keinen ausweg aus
dem pflege desaster
[Musik]